hello again dear viewers you know what
it is and what it does it being the
anomatron 6000 our hyper-advanced
simulation computer it also being one of
today's combatants the horrifying
creature created by stephen king in his
1986 novel the most popular form of this
shape-shifting fear-eating monster being
pennywise the dancing clown and we
thought what if pennywise met the scp
foundation's resident lover of fear
scp-2006 also known as too spooky well
let's turn on the device and find out it
was the summer of 1989 and for all
across the united states it was the time
of freedom of childhood wonder splashing
through creeks searching for frogs
flying kites and riding their bikes as
fast and as far as they could before it
was time to be home for dinner at the
scp foundation however there was no
summer break no lazy days lounging by
the pool no trips to the corner ice
cream shop to sample every flavor before
finally picking one and certainly no
trips to the beach he never thought he'd
say this but agent adams was beginning
to miss dumping sand out of his shoes at
the end of a long day tending to the
sunburn he always seemed to get instead
he was working sitting on board a
foundation-owned helicopter staring down
at the beautiful sun-soaked landscape
below and wishing he too could be having
a little bit of summer fun but there was
no time to dwell on the past no day for
daydreams he needed to bring his
attention back to the task at hand
transporting this anomaly to its new
containment site it was hard to keep
himself focused he had to admit there
wasn't much company on board it was just
him the pilot the shy quiet agent paul
and scp-2000
adams didn't know too much about the
entity he had to admit he hadn't seen
too much of it only crossed paths with
it once or twice currently it was
contained in a miniature portable
version of its airtight containment cell
the little he had seen of the creature
had been confusing and to be honest a
little bit ridiculous it was hairy sort
of like a gorilla but more like a man in
a cheap gorilla halloween costume and
wore an old-school space helmet on its
head complete with two goofy antennae
jutting out of the top he had laughed
out loud when he first saw it but a
supervisor had reprimanded him harshly
and promised that if he was caught
laughing at scp-2006 again he would be
reassigned to a far more dangerous
anomaly he didn't want to screw around
with either scp-682
or
scp-106 so he made sure to stifle his
urge to giggle the next time he saw the
absurd creature
now sitting on the helicopter listening
to the whirring of the blades and
wishing he had thought to bring a book
he couldn't help but ponder the nature
of the entity he was helping transport
so what's this thing's deal he asked
agent paul who had been silently working
on a newspaper crossword puzzle he had
brought with him what
scp-2006 yeah what's up with it it's
kind of you know silly right agent
paul's eyes widened and put her fingers
to his lips shh you can't say stuff like
that agent adams held up his hands in
surprise whoa buddy sorry to offend no
no no agent paul shook his head you
don't get it we need to act like this
thing is terrifying got it he lowered
his voice i know it's kind of funny when
i first saw that thing it transformed
into a killer tomato from an old movie
for crying out loud but the higher-ups
don't want it to figure out what
actually scares people so we have to
play along like when a little kid jumps
out from behind a chair and a monster
mask and you give them a big fake scream
so they can feel powerful it's like that
only the fate of humanity rests in the
balance agent adams couldn't help
himself with that comment
seriously
how does protecting this thing's ego
affect the fate of humanity agent paul
rolled his eyes so hard it looked like
he might hurt himself because
adams this is a creature whose only goal
in the world its favorite thing to do
its entire life's purpose is to scare
human beings that's all it wants
right now it's not that great at it
because it's idea of what's scary is
based on a bunch of horrible drive-in
horror movies from the 50s but if it
ever figured out the kind of stuff that
really scares people i mean really truly
pee your pants level scares people who
knows what it could do imagine if it say
it got a look at scp-173 or even a more
recent horror movie like what if this
thing saw a nightmare on elm street and
decided to start cutting people up with
freddy krueger hands seriously you need
to learn to think before you speak agent
adams nodded thoughtfully taking in the
surprising outbursts from such a usually
quiet guy well okay dang i had no idea
maybe you should pay more attention
during briefings agent paul snarked
adams was just about to retort when the
helicopter suddenly veered to the left
with a lurch there was a grinding sound
metal on metal and it quickly became
apparent that something was wrong with
the helicopter something's wrong i never
seen anything like this before the pilot
shouted from his position at the
controls this thing's going down and
we're gonna have to jump if we don't
want to go down with it what about scp
2006 agent paul panicked unless it has a
parachute we'll have to leave it to fend
for itself the pilot was already suiting
up with his own emergency parachute
making his way to the door of the
helicopter i suggest you get moving if
you don't feel like exploding today that
was all agent adams needed to shock him
out of his temporary crisis-induced
paralysis he grabbed the last two
parachutes on board tossed one to the
very pale extremely sweaty agent paul
and prepared to make the jump to what
would hopefully be safety he batted the
side of
scp-2006's mobile containment unit
half-heartedly sorry buddy was all he
could think to say before he took a deep
breath tried not to throw up and
followed the pilot diving out of the
helicopter toward the ground below he
heard agent paul jump out right behind
him and soon the only sound he could
hear was the roaring of the wind in his
ears as his fingers fumbled with the rip
cord on his harness he pulled it and the
parachute ballooned out doing its job
and carrying him slowly down to earth he
landed with a grunt feeling around for
any broken bones thankfully he had
landed smoothly a few moments later
agent paul landed a great deal less
smoothly but still very much in one
piece the pilot was already dusting
himself off several feet away from the
two men in the distance they could hear
the booming sound of the helicopter
crashing and agent adams winced
poor guy
poor us agent paul added where are we
anyway somewhere in maine the pilot
shrugged small town nearby from the
looks of it he pointed toward the nearby
sign and the other two men side with
relief civilization somewhere they could
get cleaned up get a bite to eat and
apologetically call for backup nice
agent adams grinned paul you're from
this part of the country you know this
town darry agent paul shook his head
nope never even heard of it agent adams
shrugged and he agent paul and the pilot
slowly made their way into the
unassuming little town of derry maine it
was lovely idyllic even such a picture
of small town bliss that they didn't
even notice just how many missing
posters were stapled to the telephone
poles the wide eyes have lost children
seeming to watch them as they passed
meanwhile on the other side of town in
the middle of the marshy barrens where
so many children had gone missing that
summer and the summer 27 years before it
a figure was climbing out of the
smoldering wreckage of the helicopter it
was big and furry with massive paws and
that silly metal helmet on top of its
head
scp-2006 had survived and was taking its
first free steps in decades it looked
around at the wilderness the trees the
rocks the running water and the entrance
to the town's sewers it barely
understood any of what it was seeing but
it knew that it was in a brand new place
one that would hopefully be filled with
brand new people to scare oh how
exciting to think about seeing new faces
eyes wide with dread mouths open and
screams the creature was in its favorite
most fearsome form too the mighty and
terrible role man from the 1953 classic
robot monster none could behold this
shape without collapsing in terror
scp-2006 clapped its hands together
delightedly laughing to itself it had
been nervous when the helicopter started
to fall out of the sky but now it seemed
that this was the best thing that could
have possibly happened with no one in
the immediate vicinity to frighten 2006
decided to wander off through the woods
in search of fresh victims after all now
that it was free from that awful box
there was plenty of time to look and an
endless amount of scares to be given the
creature ambled down the road past a
public park a vintage diner and rows and
rows of little houses a woman passed
walking her dog
scp-2006 roared at her expanding its
arms wide and standing up on its tiptoe
to appear as large as possible fear me
for i am roman
that's nice dear the lady passively
remarked stopping to let her dog sniff
2006's leg it lifted its own leg and
urinated on the creature's fur how dare
you i am monstrous quake with fear
2006 bellowed but the lady only chuckled
shook her head and continued on her way
puzzled the creature continued to walk
along the road looking for more victims
to terrorize and strike fear into their
fragile hearts up ahead a group of
little children playing with a soccer
ball perfect 2006 crouched low to the
ground and snuck up on the group hiding
behind a bush before popping out with a
wild yell crumble before the mighty
roman
it shouted one child screamed startled
but his friends immediately began to
tease him calm down you big baby it's
just a guy in a suit one of his friends
thumbed him with a soccer ball another
boy who was eating a cherry popsicle
laughed loudly at the side of the entity
nice costume loser he blew a raspberry
and threw the popsicle at 2006's head
sugary frozen slurry dripping down its
fur why aren't you afraid
scp-2006 demanded unable to grasp how it
lost its scaring abilities so quickly
perhaps something had gone wrong during
the crash or perhaps this town was just
filled with unusually brave people
whatever it was 2006 wanted to figure
out the answer and fast after all who
was as cp 2006 if it wasn't scary
because we're not scared of some nerd in
a chewbacca suit barf bag the kid with
the soccer ball threw it at 2006 who
caught it its claws puncturing the ball
and flattening it hey this doofus broke
our ball kick his butt it is you who
should be concerned with your butts scp
2006 retorted changing its face to the
shape of a werewolf from a classic black
and white film it bared its teeth
rubbery tongue walling out of its mouth
glassy eyes staring in two different
directions whoa how'd you do that the
angry boy lowered his fists gaping and
awe never mind that was kind of cool
bummer about the ball though the first
boy's side fed up with all this
confusion
scp-2006 dropped the deflated ball to
the ground then promptly turned and
walked in the opposite direction hey
where's he going the kid demanded but
the anomaly did not respond one boy
began bragging about his new collection
of baseball cards and their attention
was soon pulled away from the strange
being that they believed to be a person
in a monster costume then as scp-2006
walked it heard the sound it had been
waiting to hear all day
screams glorious screams of absolute
terror the purest sound of fear it
sounded like a child shrieking at the
top of their lungs in the face of
something truly horrifying where could
that wonderful noise be coming from and
why hadn't scp 2006 been the one to
inspire it the anomaly was desperate to
get to the bottom of things it followed
the sound searching for its source but
just as the sound grew louder and the
creature got closer it cut off all of a
sudden as if swallowed up by something
all-encompassing hello
scp-2006 called out in vain where did
you go come back so that i can scare you
please
i am roman hi there roman a voice piped
up from behind the entity it spun around
looking for whoever just spoke hello who
is it
scp-2006 could not see anyone only the
suburban street the houses the empty
yards down here the voice called this
way the voice was coming from a storm
drain down in the darkness below
scp-2006 could barely make out a pair of
eyes a white painted face a red nose and
a pair of bright red lips
scp 2006 shouted out the person in the
storm drain it burst into a fit of
giggles
oh that was very good what's your name
the clown asked i am roman the mighty
the fearsome scp 2006 replied nice to
meet you i'm pennywise the dancing clown
the clown grinned showing a mouth full
of sharp teeth come a little closer why
don't you maybe we could be friends
scp-2006 was perplexed but approached
just the same the clown took a deep
breath catching a whiff of the entity's
unfamiliar scent and it frowned what are
you
pennywise asked the friendly affection
gone from his voice and face you don't
smell right to me not like anything i've
ever smelled i told you are you scared
2006 replied pennywise laughed at this a
wild unhinged cackle
[Laughter]
i'm not scared of you
are you scared the clown stared at 2006
its wide orange eyes glinting in the
light of course not i'm much scarier
than you are
you're funny
you're funny the clown exclaimed very
funny why don't you come down here with
me want to float we all do down here i'm
not funny as cp 2006 pounded i'm scary
sure sure
whatever you say the clown waved the
words away don't you want to come over
here we could be friends
consciously the anomaly approached the
storm drain leaning down to get a better
look at the strange clown
suddenly the clown's hand shot out
grabbed hold of scp-2006's arm the
clown's mouth stretched open wide
revealing rows upon rows of teeth and a
seemingly impossible stretch of darkness
inside of its jaws pennywise bit down on
the anomaly's arm pulling it into the
storm drain trying to swallow it whole
like a snake swallows its prey but as it
tried to devour scp-2006
it began to choke its body rejecting the
entity and it spat the furry anomaly
back out
scp-2006 landed in the water inside of
the sewer with a wet plop as pennywise
rubbed at its jaw thoughtfully
hmm
you really are strange the clown frowned
i told you before i'm scary i'm scary
scp-2006 insisted sure you are pennywise
grimaced is that the shape you use to
scare people
scp-2006 nodded among others this is my
most successful though pennywise shook
its head i know a thing or two about
fear it's what i use to season my meat
fear is what i do
and you though you've got a lot to learn
about fear
would you
show me how to be
more scary
scp-2006 asked pennywise laughed again a
hacking coughing sound
you know what i will the more frightened
children in this town the better as long
as you understand this is my turf
scp-2006 nodded furiously i understand
pennywise beckoned the entity over and
motioned for it to sit down
fear is personal everyone is afraid of
something different and there is a
unique way to tap into each person's
deepest fears normally i look like this
like pennywise the dancing clown clowns
are funny children like clowns but
they're also terrified of clowns
pennywise did a little jig laughing
wildly
it makes them taste so sweet when they
meet me like this and think i'm a friend
and then i show them what i truly am the
clown buried its teeth humans aren't
scared of clowns scp 2006 shook its head
in my experience they only think clowns
are funny they laugh at them now this is
scary
scp-2006 concentrated and changed its
shape it was a giant rabbit from the
film knight of the lepus this strikes
terror into their hearts
no it doesn't penny wise rolled its eyes
listen to me suppose a child has a fear
of birds maybe he watched a movie about
a giant paradox maybe he was attacked by
a bird as a baby maybe it was both you
could try something like this pennywise
shifted forms then changing from a clown
to a giant bird with sharp talons a
massive wingspan a pointed beak and wild
eyes or say the child is afraid to cross
a stream because he's afraid of piranhas
the shape of pennywise changed again as
piranhas plopped into the water below
swimming around in a ravenous swarm so
being scary is about animals scp 2006
cocked its head to the side confused
pennywise resumed its clown form growing
increasingly frustrated no it's
it's about a person's darkest thoughts
the images that come to them while they
lie in bed and struggle to fall asleep
say
there's a little boy who lives in fear
of sickness his mother planted the fear
in his head you see
all day long he imagines little bacteria
crawling across his skin infections
waiting to slip inside and rot him from
the inside out to him i would look like
this pennywise changed into the shape of
a leper a man covered with sores and
limbs about to drop off with a hacking
diseased cough then
it was a clown again
or say there's a girl who fears one
person more than anyone else in the
whole world her father a man who was
once kind to her maybe but loss anger
and drink have turned him wrong made
anger curdle into violence inside his
heart to her i would only need to look
like him to say all the things she's
afraid he thinks pennywise looked at
scp-2006 do you understand now i think
so the anomaly chirped so i should try
something like this it transformed into
something large smooth and slimy it was
one of the frogs from the 1972 film
frogs this will bring any person to
their knees with fright no
pennywise bellowed no no no no no no you
don't get it so many things are scary
spiders being abandoned by your friends
being loved being buried alive a man
with no head a missing poster for
someone who isn't missing it but you
you're not scary you're not scary at all
scp-2006 huffed even when i do this it
turned into the shape of a fluffy alien
with glowing red eyes and decidedly fake
looking paper mache arms pennywise the
dancing clowns sat down on the ground
resting his head in his hands with a
long exhausted sigh
listen kid i thought this would be fun
but
i'm so tired you're not scary i can't
eat you what am i supposed to do with
you
i've got a good thing going here and i
have for a very
very long time you being here it's
messing things up just get out of my
town
you're embarrassing me go on get out of
derry find some other town to scare this
one's full well you didn't have to be so
rude about it scp-2006 huffed but it
listened just the same it left derry
maine behind walking off down the open
road just in time for an unmarked van
from the scp foundation to pull up
beside it and open the door
roman
called out agent paul you're very
frightening and we almost didn't stop
because you frightened us so much but do
you do you need a ride in exchange for
promising not to tear us apart with your
mighty claws of course will you take me
to more people i can scare 2006 asked
agent paul hid his smile and beckoned
the creature inside
you got it buddy now go check out
scp-2006
too spooky and 25 most frightening scps
for more terrifying journeys into the
world of the scp foundation